let's go next to
uh why don't we go to tebow
from brussels belgium tebow you're on
the air
hi david can you hear me i can hear you
perfectly
so first i wanted to ask um how are
people
coping in america with like the stimulus
checks
because i am raised by a single mother
and she
um has a beauty salon and in belgium
all the contact jobs um or close contact
jobs had to close for several months and
my brother just got
every month she got an amount of money
proportionate to her income
and i just can't imagine um how
americans
can live without paychecks for so many
months
it's uh it's it there's a there's a
range i mean you know fortunately
lots of people had jobs that translated
to work from home
but many people did not of course um
a lot of people are on unemployment and
struggling on unemployment in fact we
did a story earlier this week on the
bonus show
that's the award-winning bonus show
tebow by the way
we did a story on the bonus show about
how
one-third of those receiving
unemployment in february
were struggling to pay for food and
housing so the even people on
unemployment are struggling right now
a lot of younger people have moved back
in with parents i mean there's not one
it's a very good question there's not
one answer
but different people are coping in
different ways into different degrees
but it's it's pathetic
what what hasn't been done here compared
to what europe has done
yeah and like um is it also in america
that also
certain jobs had to just close for
several months or
is it just a state by state legislated
well the answer is yes but it was based
on a state-by-state basis so there were
long periods where
in certain states things like you know
massage therapy was just
closed um hair salons closed things like
this
it is decided upon at the state level so
there's kind of like a
different answers in different states
but yeah that was that was the case
okay i understand yeah and i just wanted
to ask you also about
um bernie sanders sure um like he is
i believe uh the chairman of the senate
budget committee right
um like what is what are his powers or
what can he
basically get done for you guys it's not
clear
i mean listen the powers are enumerated
you could just google exactly what the
powers are and it has to do with agenda
setting in that
in that committee um what he can do
unilaterally is
is very much unclear and he's still
going to need to build consensus with
the broader democratic party i think but
it's still a good thing to have him in
that role
but if people are expecting bernie to
unilaterally get
a ton done because he's in that position
i think that that expectation probably
will leave you disappointed
and did the establishment um give him
that position
or did he get voted to that chair
position he was voted to he he was
selected by the senate for that
yeah i mean isn't that like pretty great
for progressives
absolutely i mean the question will be
things are abnormal right now because of
the pandemic
once things normalize then we will get
to see
okay from the progressive agenda what
will be done
and what can bernie help push along in
his role as senate budget chairman we
just don't know yet
because like in the house like the
progressive candidates like aoc
yeah um they just didn't get like
any high positions right that is
essentially correct
and um we will see if that changes in
2022.
yeah okay thanks those are my questions
thank you so how are things okay in
brussels otherwise it's one of my
favorite cities
yeah we just had like uh some really bad
news we had
uh an incident um not yesterday but the
day before uh with gay bashing
so some young people um
went on a a gay meeting app and
they uh made contact with an old man
they just
um waited on him
like in a park or something and that man
was killed
oh my god sexuality so we're currently
facing that and
like the whole country is now yeah a
little bit shocked
that's that's horrifying to end on a
high note can you still get the really
great fries in brussels with the
different sauces or is that shut down
because of the pandemic
uh we have the best fries in the world
right no i don't disagree
uh our the french fries were originally
from belgium so you can't say they are
really french fries but um we make the
best fries and yeah we still have them
but
a lot of chinese people um
come come to belgium to like open
uh how do you say it um like if
a french fry business okay a fry shop we
have
yeah we have so many but they make
really good
french fries but yeah it's really funny
what's your favorite sauce the curry
ketchup or what
oh no uh we have this one sauce called
yopy sauce
okay it's like this yellow sauce i don't
know where it's coming from
but uh if you ever come to belgium it
could be anything
it could be anything yeah no no i've
been to belgium i tried a bunch of the
sauces i did not i did not try that one
but uh yellow i will go for any day you
know
yeah yeah all right tebow from brussels
i appreciate it thank you
bye all right wow wow what a call
all right let's take a quick break if
you're holding to talk to me please
don't hang up because i'm going right
back to the phones in just a moment
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plug-in
let you give each company a randomized
virtual credit card number that you
create out of thin air it'll
even autofill the card number with one
click and the payment is
taken out of your checking account
without the merchant
ever knowing your real information so
this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them
you can delete them anytime you want so
when you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over if i use a virtual credit card
number
you're keeping your identity private by
not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or credit card
info protected
against data breaches and identity theft
and it's free
and like i said you'll get five dollars
to spend when you sign up at
privacy.com slash pacman